[Music]
Rex is a really good boy
this is pixel right here he's a little
Corgi and this is ton this is Lou Reed
we call him Louie I actually hope he's
gonna go for the cheapest food but I
feel like it's luck of the draw he's not
a picky eater at all he's literally
eaten poop they're gonna go cuckoo over
being able to actually eat something
other than their normal food I've never
seen him stop eating and I've never seen
him choose not to eat something
[Music]
TUC went straight for the expensive food
pixal immediately goes for the medium
grade dish then goes for the very
expensive stuff but seems to be very
interested in the medium grade dude so
Rex just goes straight for the expensive
food no hesitation he just sucks it up
super quick and then he goes to the
medium one and he slows down a little
bit leave some left and then goes the
third one he's losing some steam but
he's still gone you still chomping down
but yeah it seems like he really really
likes the expensive one I'm not happy I
mean we named him Lou Reed we know he he
expects a lot he's gonna still live with
low to medium priced food
[Music]